say to Joe thanks for joining us on
again the program today really
appreciate your time now you are only 53
years old you're at the peak of your
powers in politics that you've recently
announced that you're going to be
standing down at the next election it
was a shock to quite a lot of people
around Westminster it's the first
interview you've done since you told the
world you have decided to go why are you
walking away well these decisions are
never easy and there's no such things
perfect timing but what actually
happened is that the party has asked all
conservative MPS to say what their
intentions are and for all the right
reasons and I've given a straight answer
but it is something I've been thinking
about a lot over the summer you know
when I left it after I left as health
secretary and uh and reflected on things
and the first thing I say Beth is I'm
you know I've been very lucky I've been
in Parliament now for what 12 years and
almost all of that time I've spent on
the front line in six different
departments I'm proud of what I I've
done and the opportunities that I've
been given it's been a privilege and
whether it was Community secretary
helping after the grenfell tragedy as a
Home Secretary with the the Windrush
Scandal and keeping the country safe
Chancellor helping to deliver brexit and
obviously most recently with the
battling through the pandemic so I'm
proud of that but I think there Comes A
Time for everyone to move on and and
what I will also say is that you know it
feels like in the last decade it's
almost like politics has been on some
kind of fast forward you know one crisis
after another one international
challenge after another and uh and
that's the way it is and you know
politicians are across parties they're
trying their best in that but it does
take a personal toll on you as well as
me as an individual of course but also
my family and you know when I came into
politics my kids were all very young and
their schools and now they're young
adults most of them and uh yeah I don't
want to miss out you know too much and
so I just think it's time for a change
but also I'll stay engaged in the in the
issues and the campaigns that I really
believe I mean you as you've said it
there you've been chance you've been
home secretary you've been Health
secretary you ran for the leadership
twice it's part of your reason then that
you've got nowhere left to go in
politics that you've kind of come to the
end of the road no I I wouldn't I
wouldn't say that I I as I say I've been
privileged to have the roles that I've
had under you know three different Prime
Ministers and I'm proud of what I've
been able to do but as I say there's no
perfect time on this that I think for
all politicians at some point of course
their their Korean politics comes to an
end and I and I feel that I'm at a stage
where I still feel young enough to to to
to to to to do other things but also to
to do that important thing of of
spending more time with your loved ones
with your family and what you the Prime
Minister you you you you're close
friends you work together in the
treasury what did he say when you told
him did he try to dissuade you Rishi I
think Rishi understood I mean Rishi
understands and uh is a great man and
and he's also very much a family man too
and uh and I I think it's actually great
he's put himself forward in this way and
it is doing what he can for the country
but you know at a personal human level
of course he understands did he did he
offer you a job in October was that is
that part of the reason that you don't
like being on the back benches no it's
not it's not part of the reason it's I I
made up my mind uh in the summer and uh
I I didn't say anything for a while yeah
uh because there was you know we were
just obviously coming back to Parliament
there was a lot of change going on in
Parliament we've been through they won
our second prime minister yeah since
then quite a lot of time but uh I felt
now towards the end of the year we're
about to obviously go into a new year I
just thought it was the time was right
given the party had asked every MP and I
just thought let's just be straight and
give an answer and such you say the odds
are stuck against the conservatives at
the moment
um it seems crazy that doesn't it in a
way uh this is the week where three
years ago
Boris Johnson won a majority of 80 seats
it was the biggest conservative majority
since the days of Margaret Thatcher how
did it go so wrong well there's
first of all I'd say that the the big
International crisis that we've seen
that has affected every country the
pandemic the the one of the the the
biggest challenges I think as country
has faced since the second world war and
and that was going to be tough for any
incumbent government it didn't help by
the way in dealing with the pandemic
that we saw the rules were broken in
Downing Street and people didn't like
that and rightly they didn't like that
and that hurt Boris Johnson in
particular that hurt the government at
the time you were one of the first to
resign from his you were the fast in
that run of people resigning to resign
you resigned and then Rishi sunat
resigned and then dozens of people
resigned after you and that was the week
that Boris Johnson himself was forced
out of down the street when he toyed a
return
or an attempt to get back to be prime
minister in October what did you think
of that
well look I I backed Rashi at that point
and that's what I wanted to see and look
I I don't know what what was he or his
team might be thinking at that time and
it's really you know it's he was a
conservative MP and he is considered MP
he has every right to stand for the
leadership but I think we came out with
the right result and it was testing
during that time but we've come out with
the right result and we have amongst all
conservative MPS we have the best
possible leader we could have right now
and I do want to ask you about Liz
trauss Rishi sunup was your Deputy the
treasury before you resigned as
Chancellor and you've just said that you
think he's the best leader and you think
he's a really smart guy and you've been
full of praising this interview for him
but you back to Liz trust in the summer
because you preferred her approach to
the economy even though Rishi warned it
was fantasy economics how did quickly
did you realize such that you'd made a
mistake I wanted to see tax cuts I think
a lot of people did I liked what Liz was
saying about you know focusing on on
growth uh but but clearly you know when
she got into office uh what she actually
did and how she did it was was very
different right I I think it was uh
obvious right from the start really that
uh that that she wasn't going to be up
to the job in what way well because even
look even if you look back now even
before let's say that you know the
biggest challenge was the economy yeah
and if you look back and even before
that mini budget
in the run-up to that mini budget you
know the the sort of fighting that was
going on behind the scenes with uh the
bank of England I think was just
completely wrong you've got to respect
an independent bank of England uh the
sidelining of the obr the the
independent of the office of budget
responsibility I think that was
completely wrong and then also uh before
that budget firing the the permanent
Secretary of the Treasury was completely
wrong I mean this was a gentleman's a
Tom scholar that has been serving
government over three decades he was my
permanent secretary he's one of the best
civil servants we have in this country I
think just treating someone like that in
that way was unacceptable do you think
the mistakes of that mini budget could
cost the conservatives the election the
next election like it was a it was a
tough time uh but uh I don't think that
that period that six-week period is
going to cost us the election also when
when Jeremy Hunt came in as as
Chancellor and took the reins there that
he and then she soon after him they
moved very quickly to stabilize the
market and let's get on to the NHS
because you've both been the controller
of the past strings and the guy that's
controlling huge budgets uh when you
were Health secretary between June 2021
and July 2022 now the government are
locked in a dispute with narcissism for
pay nurses striking for the first time
in their history 70 000 appointments
will be canceled today there there's in
that estimate now former cabinet Mr
Jacob Jake Berry said last night the
government offers too low and the
government's going to have to improve
its offer on pay he's right isn't he
well at first sight it adds Health
secretary I had the privileged saying
firsthand our health workers and you're
doing their jobs and obviously including
our nurses and and what I thought day
after day were fantastic people doing
incredible work working very very hard
off especially during of course the
pandemic when it comes to pay I I do
understand at the moment whether it's
nurses it's other workers and off about
the pressures they're feeling I mean who
isn't feeling pressure when inflation is
at such a level you know almost everyone
in this country is taking a real terms
pay cut in in one sense or another but
when it comes to the NHS you have to do
what's fair of course and you have to do
what's affordable and I do think it is
fair that uh the government
did what it did which is accept the
recommendations of an independent
pay-per-view body I think the idea of a
I think the the RCN the nurses Union is
asking for a 19 pay rise I just don't
think it is Affordable no and I I think
that that probably would be a kind of
widespread view that 19 is a huge amount
but do you accept that they're going to
have to go up a bit like just in
practice more nasty strikes in January
it's your worst nightmare as a health
secretary the prospects of more strikes
do you not think it's going to force the
government to just it doesn't have to be
a double-digit pay rise necessarily but
to give a bit more to us no I
I don't accept that because I think you
have an independent pay review system
for a reason it is genuinely I've seen
this firsthand in whether it was as
health secretary as Home Secretary when
it came to policing and it's an
independent system when you were Health
sector I went back and checked the
numbers you were tasked with dealing
with the backlog when you started it was
5.3 million I went and checked this
morning back in June 2021 it's now
7.2 million is the system breaking the
health system here in this country well
first why is it going up when I started
I also said that the NHS had estimated
that because of the pandemic that some
10 million people stayed away from the
NHS not all of them are going to come
back but the NHS has I think sensibly
estimated at least half of them do and
that is why I also said it's going to go
up the waiting list before it comes down
and sadly I think it's going to still
continue to go up for a while before it
comes down so that's what's happening
the the sort of second part of your
question but is it is it sustainable um
look I having worked up close now with
the with the health service and you know
I I don't think the the model of the NHS
as it was set up some 70 years ago is is
sustainable for the future you know that
the world has changed and the NHS has
not moved on right with that and and
Beth even before the pandemic it was
heading in that direction and that you
know because of the changing demography
you know people living longer therefore
needing more health care and social care
for that matter new medicines and
needing that as well of course everyone
rightly wants to get access to to new
medicines and treatments and also the
changing burden and disease you know we
have a lot more abuse people today we
have a lot more problems with addictions
so the NHS needs to change with that and
then if that wasn't challenging enough
something the pandemic comes along and
makes it much much worse when you say
the model of the NHS is not sustainable
in its current form the NHS is funded
through General taxation that is that
what you're saying that the way we fund
it at the moment is not sustainable
because it's it's breaking is that what
you're saying we need to look at
different ways
Fund in the NHS I think we need to look
at a a number of things as a country and
we need to have an honest debate about
the future of the NHS because we all
want it to be there for us in the future
for ourselves for our children providing
us with with really good health care and
and I think you know we we count no one
should pretend that that is where it's
what it's what it's doing because at the
moment people seem to be queuing for
everything and uh and we can't pretend
it's gonna suddenly get there without
radical change now when it comes to the
funding model I you know I'm not gonna
make sort of uh you know point to that
on the hoop without looking at the
detail but I would I would say that a
starting point would be to look at the
Universal Health Care Systems in other
large European countries if you speak to
any German you might know or a French
person an Italian you know they they
have good Health Care Systems which were
also challenged by the pandemic but they
seem to be all be doing better than we
are at the moment and and also if I may
add to that I think other things that we
need to to look at is folks a lot more
prevention you know the NHS was was set
up in its day for dealing with people
when they get ill it only spends
something like you know three or four
percent of its Budget on prevention why
can't politicians in this country have
the conversation that you can now have
with me because you are not at the front
line anymore about how to make the NHS
the moment a politician of any party
says something that is obviously correct
about the NHS and and the challenge it
faces that someone else will just jump
down their throat and uh and and turn it
into something else you know turn into
the big negative you know there was a
story recently uh for example Beth about
I think I read a couple of weeks ago I
think it was in Scotland yeah
there were some leak someone called you
know a discussion they had about maybe
some co-payment now I don't know whether
that's exactly the right system or not
but I actually welcome having that kind
of discussion you know because we need
to have this honest debate as a country
why that won't survive because look if
you look at
the NHS now
the only way it is
dealing with this record demand this
levels of demand is by rationing by
queuing and people are queuing for the
operations they're queuing for their
Diagnostics they're queuing for
ambulances they're queuing for GPS and I
don't think anyone thinks that's a
sensible way to go forward and there's
no there's no overnight fixed magic
solution to that so you have to find a
way to to to help more with the demand
side of things as in you know more work
on prevention but also in the let's call
it the supply of healthcare I've got a
last question for you go for it this I
would like an honest answer you've
actually been very honest in this
interview you're a cabinet minister
you're in six departments you juggled
lots of policy areas and lots of
challenges what was your biggest success
and what was your biggest failure
or biggest failure
I I I don't know
um
you have to have to come back for that I
mean they're they're where their
failures yesterday I mean I did you know
it's uh we all have uh challenges and
not everything works out the way you've
planned it uh in terms of um success
I I probably go back to Omicron when
that happened was just over a year ago
and uh there was lots of advice I was
getting from you know another lockdown
to don't do anything and in the end we
obviously decided I decided to rely on
pharmaceutical defenses and that meant
trying to boost all adults or 20 million
adults Yeah by Christmas within six
weeks and lots of people said it
couldn't be done and and the NHS and
everyone that worked on it you know in
more than did that 20 million people
boosted and I think it stayed the
country from a lockdown when I said
failure what popped into your mind
something did no I I need to think about
it okay but I'm not I'm not but don't
get me wrong I'm not saying that because
I think they haven't been failures uh I
I think in any in any successful uh Walk
of Life that you you you don't get
everything and also you learn from
failure right I mean nothing can go
right all the time I know that all too
well as you leave politics what's one
thing you regret leaving on the table as
unfinished business how about that for
final question
um I I think we've just talked about it
and that's the NHS because it's uh it's
something it's so big it's something we
all rely on and I would have in a way
like to have more time to to to look at
reform to have that honest debate but
it's something I'd like to stay involved
in and and continue to campaign for uh
to get those improvements whether I'm in
politics or not such Javed thank you so
much for your time appreciate it thank
you